you know the big middle Tower in Paris
Everyone likes to visit you know the one
that takes 1600 steps to reach the top
well they don't let people do stunts off
of that very often except today's guests
got a little special exception
it's so crazy that you guys really shot
that now this Legend is not only a stunt
performer turned coordinator turned
director but he's also an amazing human
being JJ Perry please tell us more about
yourself uh I've been a stunt man for 33
years I've been very fortunate to get in
this business and work with some of the
greats and the greats and the greats
we're gonna get some stories directly
from the source here
insane stories like jumping off of a
mountain with Andy Chang in Hawaii this
is gravity
launching a flaming car off of a ramp in
reverse
he might have gotten killed I thought he
was going to get killed and literally
folding a person in half in his
directorial debut did you should have
seen Jamie's face the first time he
followed her he was like
yeah we have a banger for you today so
people without further Ado let's jump in
[Music]
we're gonna kick things off with this
fight scene from day shift and when I
saw it I had never really seen anything
like this before true it's pretty a
pretty amazing scene to open a movie
with
foreign
yeah this is the creepy creepy creepy
and then I wanted the audience to think
what's what is he doing right telling
the story of the guillotine wire I was a
big fan of flying Guillotine back from
the 70s actually clearing hours trying
to do a tactical practical reality plus
20 percent
oh no what do you
Buckshot mouthwash baby sorry Grandma I
actually wanted to have my mom play this
character because of kovid it was we
weren't unable to bring her oh wow yeah
the first girl that went into the gut
ratchet was to let Craddock we're pretty
much from this moment on we are with
this fight double shy shy shy comes in
here shy is a ballistic nightmare she's
so badass yes she is it was the double
for Jamie oh we had Travis Parker who is
a dear dear friend of mine an amazing
stun man he's been on the road with us
for quite a while and he's definitely
one a huge asset
I love that mirror shot yeah yeah so we
definitely wanted to play into vampire
lore and you know why they can't see
because old mirrors are made with silver
in them
now we're into a contortionist named
Jordan and this girl was amazing a real
trooper her first movie
Here Comes Motorola three two one
we call that the Motorola
Here Comes This is a this is a standing
Motorola coming
oh my God that's a reverse Motorola and
you should have seen Jamie's face the
first time he followed her he was like
I was like Bobby it's okay it's okay
we shot all of these reactions in
Reverse okay so we would start them in
their second position and wire them out
in their first position so there's a
little bit of a bump that would happen
it'd be three two one between the one of
one there was a bobble head and then on
the go of go we would pull them out
interesting I mean it looks great it's
such a smart idea because like doing it
forwards with a contortionist I imagine
you're gonna over bend over stress so
here's the problem contortions are
amazing athletes but it's all slow
twitch muscle right there's no fast
twist fiber there so if you pull them
hard and they're already contorted you
will break something or pull something
for sure and we spent two sessions of
four days figuring out all of these gags
because I promised that it would work
but I didn't know for sure right so I
kind of hung it out there and as soon as
we got that done that's when I was like
we're on one
we mixed like a little bit of Lucha
Libre yeah and a little bit of like
practical MMA because that would be
called a standing crucifix in in MMA
yeah and I also like the crucifix look
you know the Father the Son and the Holy
Ghost
so that's a real person contorted on the
fireplace into that my whole Mantra to
this movies we're doing everything in
camera in 1990 when I got out here there
was no way you could say we're going to
fix it in post you had to be a clever
filmmaker you had to think of a way to
get it done and now we use VFX as an
enhancement like there's no way that I
could have shot her with a shotgun and
had a person healed so we had visual
effects help us with that but this is
all practical in camera reverse
photography you know like we had 42 days
to shoot this movie and we're in the
middle of a pandemic so we were under
the gun we didn't have a lot of time but
there was no time for mistakes right so
we had to rely on crafty film making and
good skilled departments yeah this is
probably one of the most fun films of
the year that I got to see and it's all
because a lot of it's in the frame you
see all of it happening and the fact
that you use such cool techniques
combining contortionism with reverse
camera we haven't seen it before and it
made it so much fun and I loved it so
thank you very much no no my pleasure
and it's you know like I can't take
credit for it I have this amazing team
like I was surrounded by these hitters
and also my production crew my camera
Department my art Department my
production designer you know I was like
every morning we laced our shoes up
tight we had a coffee and we hit the
ground running I'm so grateful so it's
not on me it's on the team it's on the
team for sure I'm usually the weakest
link in the team and that's not always
by Design
touche yeah that's awesome amazing nice
today's video is sponsored by betterhelp
in studio we actually have two people
who actively use better help for therapy
we talked to Griffin last time he gave
some great Insight but also Dean this
boy right here yeah off and on for the
past couple years I'll do like a couple
months here a couple months there it's
like a little tune-up I always leave
feeling like this lightness of just like
oh everything's fine one of the big
biggest selling points to me was the you
know they say there's over 30 000
therapists in the network and they kind
of use a questionnaire system to
identify who's who's right for you
essentially and that was the hardest
thing for me is finding somebody because
it takes me going there and speaking
with them to have you know an upfront
questionnaire that is filtering through
all these people seems to be like a
really cool way to do it when you match
with a therapist there's a whole bio
they have written up you get a lot of
information about the person what their
Specialties are and you can make a
decision of like this person sounds
right for me or they don't you're just
at your computer and it's like it feels
a lot lower stakes and you can also do
phone if there's some kind of
inconvenience you can't do it in your
place maybe go for a walk and just do it
over the phone they say that you can
schedule anytime is that like hyper
flexible or does it depend on your
therapist like how does the scheduling
side of it work literally you see a
calendar and you pick a day and you see
what times they have open you click on
it and it automatically schedules it on
the day you just hop on your little chat
and then you just join a video room and
you're in and and if you find that you
can't make your appointment you can
cancel within a day and there's no
charge no nothing this is a journey that
I'm just starting like truly here at
Corridor and I encourage you guys if you
feel like you need it or even if you
feel like you don't like make that bed
take care of yourself mentally and join
me let's do it together and and just see
see what comes of it taking care of your
mental health is one of the most
important things you can do because if
your cup is not full you can't pour into
other people and it's important to take
the time to take care of yourself so if
this sounds like something you're
interested in go to betterhelp.com
Corridor crew for 10 off your first
month anyway get out of here I need to
heal
oh
oh yeah let's do run down Andy Chang
told us that you guys went out to test
this stunt and he has you climb up a
very Steep Hill once you guys get all up
there he's like cool this is a stunt and
he jumps down himself and I just want to
know what was in your head
so we get to this place and we start
climbing and which seems like we've been
climbing a long time and like Andy how
about here say no no I keep going and
you know we're all slipping and there's
lava rock and like thorns and we get I
was like I need how about here you know
I'm look down it's like you can't even
see where we were anymore no no keep
going I look up and there's not much
more to the top we get about 10 feet
from the top and we're going to do it
from here so I chop in with my
entrenching tool and then turn away sits
down and I'm looking at Tony wise face
while I'm chopping and he's like
and there's only one person that's Happy
up there in that hand
so we're gonna go from here and he just
takes off
he's gravity
you just go and you know like you got to
look at it like it's not gonna kill me
I'm just gonna do it and just you know
yep
we ended up doing it 13 times each and
then listen hats off to Polly theopolis
and tonawai and Marco too man everybody
just took gnarly records we all got
peeled up we all got all got from this
so if anybody happens to drive their
Jeep over the edge in Hawaii and find
themselves rolling down a mountain do
you have any advice just make yourself
as circular as possible and don't like
we did it handcuffed me and me and Paul
had to be handcuffed we just held on to
Rooms oh my God you're right yeah so but
I would I would say don't reach out like
in life when you're running down a hill
that you can't stop either you reach the
end of the hill or you crash and burn
best to try and reach the end of the
Hill absolutely two
hahaha
[Music]
it was it was amazing experience it was
great to get to work with my brothers
and be a part of this you know like we
got a lot of kudos for this and Andy did
too yeah so more than anything what I'm
grateful for is to have been a part of
it to be able to help my brother who's
an amazing director and a great friend
and seeing tunnelwai's career take off
and probably the opposite maybe another
one of the toughest people I know on the
planet Marco's Aurora 2 is absolutely
rocket shipped and uh I'll be he'll be
working with me I'll be working with him
very soon again as well so yeah it was a
was a great experience you know do I
want to go back and do it again tomorrow
uh no
[Applause]
you know and I just like I just worked
in France on murder mystery too we got
to shoot a thousand feet up on the
Eiffel Tower
and here this is one of the first shots
I did when I got here oh this spot isn't
out there we did this cool fight in the
truck
oh what oh ax in the head geez it was so
much fun working with those two Sandler
and Aniston are awesome and here comes
the shot in a moment as we get to frost
this one that's practical we're at the
very top and no one's ever done that
Kelly Fallon she's the one riding this
it's so crazy that you guys really shot
that so I went down there and I get on
the first Zoom meeting there's 30 faces
on the zoom and they're talking about
how they're going to do this Eiffel
Tower thing on a set piece so I was like
why would you do that I said what do you
mean I said Eiffel Tower is basically a
stick of trust that stands up straight
just take another Stick Of Trust put it
on there and then you have like an
elevator with no floor and then you can
do that and I was like hell yeah I can
do it we can do it for sure and he goes
you're getting on a plane tomorrow we're
making that happen I was like I was like
oh
but yeah I was like cool and at the end
of the day I understood why they wanted
to do a set piece but look at 55 years
old for me now when I go places like I
took the job on back in Action that I
just got off I wanted to work with Jamie
again of course and the director of Seth
Gordon is super cool and it's a Netflix
show but I also took the job as a
challenge because I wanted to film on
the Thames I wanted to lock up London
and do a motorcycle chase that parallel
the Thames then we'd get on the Thames
and do a massive boat chase and I wanted
to do this because I wanted to shoot on
the Eiffel Tower I want to do things
that haven't been done you know like I
want to check those things off my list
as bucket list what I'd like to do next
is jump a motorcycle over the White
House and then maybe jump a car over the
Kremlin you know maybe something like
that
yeah have you done a lot of helicopter
work I have so in the Army I worked on a
helicopter quite a bit it was different
we weren't filming so there's a series
of like helicopter made for TV action
films that came out in the 70s and you
would never see this today I just wanted
what's the name of the show there's a
deadly encounter
dude no room for error somebody was in
position and somebody somebody was
handheld somebody was on stage
yeah what happens if he hits that pieces
are going to chew that guy up on these
sticks and not to mention you have to
film this from another helicopter yep
you don't just have one burden here you
have two birds in here the awareness of
your vehicle and this is maybe 70s right
so you had all these post Vietnam era
Pilots that were just doing nothing but
helicopter work in Vietnam they were
gnarly you know having to dive in quick
get people off and or deploy them out
quick it's next level and I'm telling
you it's coming from that those post
Vietnam that those Vietnam Pilots it is
different man back then there was nobody
watching for safety and everybody was
taking big chances they didn't have time
or money you know and but the
expectation was always there and you had
you know men and women out there trying
to push the envelope and they wanted to
be super cool they wanted to do
something spectacle that you want to go
see man respect you know right respect
so this part's in Mexico City I'm pretty
sure
[Music]
what you know I'm going to tell you yeah
I think things like this for me when I
see this now yeah you probably couldn't
do this a because you couldn't lock up
the airspace you know because right yeah
you'd have to be out in the middle of
the desert somewhere and be because it's
super expensive to shoot this yeah so we
always ask you know for people to
recommend stunts or movies things like
that but we've talked about eras of
action and stunt working let's go all
the way back to the 70s I'm looking for
the the older of you in the audience can
you recommend some stunts from the 70s
that we should be taking a look at in
our next episode of stuntman react or
some women react Fred North is the
Premier helicopter camera pilot and he's
done all of the Fast and Furious when we
were doing Fast and Furious 8 in Cuba
first movie to film in Cuba American
movie filming Cuba since the 50s I think
when he rocked that helicopter off the
malecon and was like five feet off the
deck I swear to God those Cubans thought
we were coming to attack them you know
you see the Russian like oh my God man I
had so much fun there in the day with
the Cuban people were just beautiful and
and genuine
[Applause]
[Music]
on huge Hollywood movie with Russian arm
we had Regis Harrington on the e-bike we
had helicopters drones everything we're
just blowing things and you know Dennis
McCarthy built these cars with LS1
Motors super gnarly fast cars and
they're light in the ass because they're
old it's hard to keep together you know
hard to keep it from looping
this is the house of Parliament and the
hell did you see the helicopter shot
yeah they were all like coming out like
whoa whoa you know and I was like it's
cool bro
and there's one last shot at the very
end when he reverses up that ramp where
Fred North where I thought he might have
gotten killed I thought he was going to
get killed check up other guy bails out
slides up to that's it and now we go
right up the ramp backwards
[Music]
this oh so Fred was rocking at it so
hard I thought he was gonna get hit the
thing oh my God I was like I was like oh
Hail Mary I was starting to throw my
phone on the floors there I would Jeff
to jump in and try to swim to get him
see he's a helicopter flying Kansas
right to it wow like who jumps the car
backwards on fire I guess we do yes
rad that's so crazy
[Music]
now we did a punch punch episode on car
stunts and drone filming yeah I heard
about that
Strangely I was in the editing room for
day shift and my wingman calls me
because hey boss you know they're doing
a shot for shopping and I was like what
cutting it but then I found out it was a
promotional thing and I'm super grateful
and I think you guys killed it man thank
you my brothers thank you my brothers
and sorry for being a crotch to the Old
redneck
that's like that's the schwannee that
you bring to things right was that
French it was a little bit holy
coming up where we 've grown Tommy fpv
from wild rabbit Tommy to be autism dear
friend he's been on the road with us now
quite a bit check out this
threw the camera out of the sunroof was
that just an idea on the day like well
no I thought about it from before and I
said can we we tested we had tested that
like it's not like flying between the
trees there like having all the
foreground elements the near misses with
the Drone you think about the audience's
perspective it's been the same in
vehicular sequences since 89 since the
implementation of the Russian arm of the
Ukraine which is a high performance
vehicle with a crane on it with a two or
four axis head the fpv has been the most
dramatic perspective change I think
since the Russian arm and we just it
just came a few years ago so I know
Michael Bay's been using it I know I've
been using I know a lot of people been
using it one of the things I love that
you do with your drone work you let it
tell a story where like the shot evolves
this shot yeah we're on the cars and we
get a sense of spacing and geography and
here come the motorcycles and yeah and
then we shift subjects here I love it
that's right I wanted everything to go
over around through you saw when the
truck drove I had this shot in the
suspension but just putting the camera
where you can't normally have the camera
getting in the audience see that
perspective for me is great action
filmmaking yeah like getting little
artists see things that they don't
normally see yeah I mean that's the
beauty of it yeah
[Applause]
so this is when I was talking about
animatic previous it was this sequence
that I animated previous for
foreign
I had to fight to keep that in the movie
shot in the movie it's so funny because
like I love these moments and not just
that you see the whole Fender coming off
yeah
is that real fire too that it was there
was a little fire element and then I
think we enhanced there was a little bit
of and you can see how it fades yeah but
what I was saying about visual effects
as a stunt coordinator I'm not a fan of
animatic previous because they're not
responsible and I am but as a director I
understand how important that tool is
and having smart people coming and
giving ideas for that so I just want to
clarify that as a director I've used I
use animatic previous and I'm happy to
use it and I'm grateful for it but
sometimes the director you know if they
don't swim in the action pond with us
they don't know how deep that water is
and all the big sharks that swim at the
bottom right they can get you we need to
manage that as stunt performers we need
to work together with animatic previous
so we're not putting each other in
awkward positions
thank you
watch this is good we watching a dummy
into the overpass which we weren't
supposed to do
better to say sorry than please
sometimes and then there's this one
right here he doesn't see this Bingo
Gringo oh sorry thanks for coming there
you go and that was our car chase so I
was super super stoked in the 90s when
it's coming up as a stunt man we'll be
doing card chases in the valley in
downtown L.A all the time and the valley
for me is one of the first places I
moved when I got out of the army was
this trippy exotic weird hot place that
I fell in love with LA from I wanted to
create that same Mystique in my movie so
anywhere people can like follow you on
Instagram JJ Loko Perry all right
thank you so much JJ for coming in I
mean it's always a learning experience
whenever I'm sitting across from you or
next to you and it didn't change today
so thank you so much for coming I
appreciate you big bro and I can't wait
to see you again thank you brother thank
you you get out of this handshake
thanks for watching Everybody we'll see
you in the next one